was geht ist marx und herzlich
willkommen zur heutigen folge minecraft
nero wir gehen direkt auf den server und
für heute habe ich einen plan und zwar
wirklich einen plan damit die folge
nicht wieder wie die letzten bisschen
ruhiger bisschen leiser machen dass die
nicht wieder wie die letzten heim lich
langwierig wird und ja unproduktiv das
nervt mich total auch wenn ich das
irgendwie nach china angucke soll ich so
jetzt erstmal ein wunderschönes baumhaus
auf dass ich ein bisschen zeug rein
schmecken kann übrigens sehr leid dass
es beim letzten mal nicht geklappt hat
und die face comeback machen teilweise
auch die tonspur ich weiß wirklich nicht
was das problem war ich glaube meine
festplatte war voll oder sonst was
das einzige was ich mir mehr oder wie es
mir erklären könnte so rein damit rein
damit weiter mit rein damit
wie gesagt ich habe einen plan für heute
der besteht zum einen daraus dass ich
endlich mit diesem ganzen ja blatt magic
zeug weitermachen und dann am ende so
leid es mir tut noch mal nach einer
gaskrise allerdings hüten dem goethe
sondern indem ich ganz einfach gegner an
nicht gegner angreifen damit sie mir
vornehme im ressort bin ich dann gucke
ich jetzt einfach mal nach blatt ruhm
weil von den insgesamt acht stück machen
stein und heißt la klinsmann also habe
ich clean stone habe ich nicht so das
war eigentlich nur eine rhetorische
frage
auch verdammt ich hab ich kein queenston
okay da muss ich erstmal eine kleine
menge klingt so farm gehen und zwar
insgesamt sekunde 8 x 8 64 klinsmann
brauche ich so alles klar
wo gehe ich da am besten runter weil ich
zu unser aller lieblings schacht wo ich
die letzte folge komme retten verbracht
habe so alles lahm
hoffentlich fällt er ist nicht noch mal
jemand rein weil ich hier rum grabe so
alles klar
wir machen das einfach irgendwie
einigermaßen effizient 64 kriegen aber
schnell zusammen vor allen dingen mit
dem pixi
und dann kriegen wir schon mal den altar
levels zwei machen uns den zweiten platz
und hat sich fragt was macht ihr da die
ganze zeit mit seinem blatt magic sword
total langweilig einerseits finde ich es
geht also langweilig wenn ich es gar
nicht ist immer cool wenn man
fortschritte macht übrigens obwohl
fortschritt ich hab mein deutscher
geschrieben war relativ neues und das
war irgendwie lustig habe über twilight
geschrieben 5 wir sollten das mit einem
literarischen werk unserer wahl belegen
und damit war eigentlich so etwas
gedacht wie goethes faust oder fräulein
else oder irgendwelche schule literatur
hat die man so liest im laufe der jahre
aber das problem ist ich hab sie halt
nicht gelesen also wirklich keine
piraten lest das zeug wirklich zumindest
die sachen die für sie relevant sind
sollte man sich unbedingt rein ziehen
weil es einfach total ätzend und schlimm
ist wenn man dann dort sitzt und dann so
wie ich überlegen muss verdammt okay wie
mache ich das jetzt damit ich halt
irgendwie ein werk mir aus zehn aus den
fingern ziehen kann
aber das ist auf jeden fall wieder ein
deutlicher schritt näher zum endlichen
abitur
damit ist endlich mal geschafft habe ich
hoffe mal dass die kohle für reiche
ausländer kann ich schon mal die animals
mir bereitliegen 5m jetzt habe ich jetzt
insgesamt die habe ich alle aus dem
dungeon geholt es gibt also doch relativ
viele wege wie man am ratsweg somit
macht mir am besten ab jetzt große kiste
den dafür muss mir auch platz schaffe
ich denk mal dass sich dann
wahrscheinlich auf dem dach obendrauf
einfach die altar verzauberung
geschichte machen werde weil wie gesagt
dafür braucht man acht von dem blut
ruhen und dann in die mitte obendrauf
packt man den altar und hat dann halt
den level 2 altar an den braucht man
halt um bestimmte zauber zu machen und
so und die ihr vielleicht wisst oder in
den letzten folgen mitbekommen habt ist
mein absolutes ziel
fliegen zu können desto besser ist da
oben eigentlich leute auf jeden fall der
anscheinend diesen diesem massaker
getötet weil der drop der dieses ding
zumindest unter anderem ich weiß nicht
welche anderen cops das auch noch als
trocken aber leider kenne ich mich kenne
ich mich nicht so wirklich aus ich hoffe
mal dass sich die ganze team nach die
gräber nicht anders ich oder kann ich
das angreifen
ich hoffe mal dass ich diese ganze team
chemie und das ist problem
hey warum kann ich ihnen dann überhaupt
erst mal anheben wenn ich ihn gar nicht
bekämpfen kann kommt im märz hinterher
ich hoffentlich nie bei 200 ist schon
eine ganze menge also tut mir leid
kollege ich wollte dich nicht
angegriffen haben ich habe auch schon
beschwerden über mein baum haus bekommen
also nicht wirklich ernst gemeinte
fernseher ich habe schon gesehen was du
da gebaut und der bildmitte sack da
drüben stresstest um hier für unsere
bude
man kann halt nichts gegen die gegen die
mars machen die man noch nicht angreifen
kann wegen die hand experience also
nicht mitfeiern ich mit tnt mit nichts
quasi so zeigt er damit und erstmal eine
double chooz daraus machen dann machen
wir das mal als lucky shot aus mit dem
steinbrück sehr gut so muss das so wenn
die zeit erlaubt gehen ich glaube das
tut sie tatsächlich dann so weit wie
heißen die dinger noch mal horst lenk
slate die dinger kann ich schon mal
machen ich weiß nicht genau wie viel von
meinem blut ich da noch opfer muss aber
ich opfer einfach mal so dass ich
einfach auf der ja es ist kein schaden
wenn man ein bisschen blut in seinem
altar drin hat bis der wienerischen
stajic kann ja noch mal nachgucken
ich brauche ich brauche insgesamt 16
slade und die brauchen jeweils 1000
okay wir brauchen 1000 jeweils fordern
weiß ich auch dass ich die ganzen lebens
punkt in dieser folge aktiviert bekomme
er wusste man bleibt ob hier so damit
kann ich auch blut opfern so deshalb
erst wieder für ein effekt der seite und
so habe ich jetzt hier auf blut im
netzwerk sein okay es versteht es tut
mir leid ich bin auch nicht also ich
beschäftige mich zwar mit diesem ganzen
glatt magic system aber so perfekt ist
es doch mal nicht alles aber ich glaube
ihr seht mir da bestimmt ein wenig nach
so kommt es spontan hilfe gleicher mehr
glück und kommt uns raus so ein kleiner
mit kann ich jetzt alles nicht
gebrauchen
so hat er wollte jetzt mal klinsmann tun
dass sich hier dem dtx lakes rauskriegen
ob das tue ich alles klar
rainer mit alles kann immer nur eine
rein und jetzt können wir beobachten wie
aus diesem queenston ein solcher blank
slate wird und es dauert eine ganze
weile ich hoffe mal das ist nicht so
extrem lange dauert und immer schön
neues flutopfern ja was anderes können
wir jetzt gerade gar nicht machen
und außer warten ich hoffe mir passiert
wirklich was ich hab's wieder raus
wollte ich den kopf
so sollte das gleich nicht funktionieren
nein nein so jetzt müssen wir einfach
mal ein bisschen geduldiger sein
beziehungsweise ich ihr seid ja
wahrscheinlich relativ geduldig ich will
welches keine vorwürfe machen so und
dann bauen wir auf eine zeit oben
bisschen weiter um nicht auch das jetzt
alles zu lange das ist total doof wenn
das jetzt so ewigkeiten dauert wir bauen
natürlich stilvoll ihr kennt mich ja man
nennt mich ja auch den stilvoll mountain
kran nicht nicht selten tut man das so
es passiert ja gar nichts habe ich
irgendwas falsch gemacht also bestimmt
habe ich etwas falsch gemacht
lol als ob sie jetzt fertig geworden ist
ok dann kann es doch eine ganze weile
dauern ich dachte wir kriegen das ganz
ganz flott in der folge heute fertig
aber anscheinend muss man da wirklich
vorsichtig sein und gucken ob wir uns
vielleicht irgendwie unter dem dem haus
irgendwelche felder anlegen können haben
wir hier irgend etwas was ich zum feld
anbauen ist außer melonen weil melonen
sind natürlich jetzt nicht so optimal
klappt karotten so was hab ich alles
gegessen schlage ich bin
naja ok haben wir natürlich vor einigen
lasse den kollegen hier unten rum
stänkern
das nervt ein bisschen und ich glaub dir
planlos wie ich bin einfach nur durch
die gegend so krainer
sie findet immer so so riskant wenn man
einfach warum mache ich das gerade so
wenn man sein eigenes blut ob hat die
ganze zeit damit und rainer mit sodann
kann ich euch jetzt schon mal zeigen
okay das ist wie man das allererste
blanks lake macht und zwar
folgendermaßen y noch den blatt ob in
die mitte und dann hat man so eine blut-
rune und von den brauchst du insgesamt
acht stück damit wir oben auf dem dach
uns unseren coolen blut alter hinstellen
können aber es für im untergrund können
wir es machen haben irgendwas nächstes
jahr wenn man ne directors sieht so ein
bisschen aus beim anbieter zeug in der
bude hängen ich wollte irgendwas cooles
nehmen dann hat meter recke einfach so
so komisches zeug und dran hängt es
stress zu wenig
mavericks kam er nicht treffen ist emma
stone zu wenig leider etwas cooles kopf
leute ein bisschen blut opfern wir das
glück regeneriert man so verhältnismäßig
schnell später übrigens kann ich auch
das blut von von monstern opfern also
macht richter keine sorgen das hier ist
jede folge tausendfach man eigentlich
blut opfern muss aber in absehbarer
zukunft würde ich sagen leute oder will
ich versprechen fast können wir mit
unserem zeigt hier fliegen wir können
fliegen wenn wir eine gastrede kriegen
deshalb habe ich mir übrigens die ganze
zeit zu den kopf gemacht ist endlich
eine gastrede finde aber ich habe jetzt
einen weg gefunden wie man das geschafft
und ich hoffe es einfach ich hoffe
einfach dass ich auf diesem weg den ich
da gefunden habe einfach wieder mit dem
gas tränen klar komme dann deine finde
weil alle alle von euch übrigens da muss
mich bei euch bedanken
ich bin ihr werk verrichten kommentieren
ich bin ein bisschen durch den wind ihr
habt mir ganz auf die kommentare
geschrieben
das ist in den dungeons und da habe ich
es auch im singleplayer irgendwie
dreimal oder so und dann wie durch
gesucht und habe wirklich immer was
gefunden
also da nochmal auf jeden fall großes
dankeschön an euch dafür eure mithilfe
definition zetsche wir haben 800 lp
drehen und warten wie gehe ich die noch
mal an den alltag haben mit rechtsklick
einfach na ja anscheinend auch nicht
okay leute irgendwie die ganzen
funktionsweise müssen wir nochmal
anschauen
aber wir machen ja auf jeden fall
ständig weiter so
aber so kann ich jetzt nur in mein
portabel system in mein portals netz
seien spenden
was natürlich jetzt für unseren
aktuellen fertige schrift lage ich mal
nicht so optimal ist ich hoffe ihr könnt
irgendwie was damit anfangen mit dieser
folge und findet was nicht total doof
was mache ich jetzt da oben führen
eine konstruktion hin ich bin ich aber
schon wieder holz machen wir das die
ganze zeit
ich denke mal dass sich das thema dass
sie das zeug brauche mach erst mal
hatten sie so gehen ja leitern wie
genommen zäune leute was wir für fragen
stellen zum glück kann man tun wenn die
items zur zacke fans auch hier das war
peinlich dass die pdk der fiskus bruder
so lauda
ich muss man schlucken muss man
klarkommen das liegt einmal wie ich rede
schon so fertig bin mache ich schon ganz
schön fertig sieben stunden am stück
eine klausur zu schreiben in deutsches
recht
das echt hart sodann haben wir gleich
drei stück wir brauchen aber 8
da geht es vielleicht noch eine ganze
folge für drauf presse herr du kannst
das zeug nicht reinlegen und einfach
chillen ist alles fertig ist und muster
dem dran stehen neues reinlegen
wieder daneben stellen wieder was neues
rating ist mit meinen ich sollte keine
kleinen um peter antwortet nicht
wahrscheinlich so wie ich ihn kenne
schreibt einfach nur kein etwa davor
auch stressig so damit wollte hier gern
weitermachen heißt komm schon
warum hat jetzt eine druckplatte ich
hab' ich denke gerade so auch die
druckplatte braucht er nicht machen
und das mache ich eine druckplatte ist
ja so herr damit und einen neuen stein
rhein zur abwechslung wird auch nachts
oder ist es einfach nur regen regen habe
ich kein problem mit nacht allerdings
schon
es würde einfach richtig schön gebaut
hier leute hab ich dir nicht längst
ausgestellt gab letztens animations
reign of trading range of aber regen
selbst ist ja schon gar nicht drin
moment tut mir leid leute rain wo ist es
denn die sehr gut jetzt habe ich den
regen komplett ausgestellt
es kann so nah gut ansonsten die
animation band black für die zukunft
noch mal machen das sieht cool aus
die veranda distance habe ich jetzt gar
nicht so sofa wie es normale
normalerweise abhängig minecraft spiele
als ok und damit und rein damit leute
kriegen wir es noch hin
ok so das packen wieder hier rein ist
klar drei platten haben wir schon mal
und das machen wir die mitte es nervt
mich total dass ich keine coolen blöcke
habe komm wir machen das jetzt einfach
mal so
so sieht einigermaßen nice auswendig
meine bude ist auch wirklich für den
anfang nur total behelfsmäßig edel meine
bude ist wie gesagt von anfangs mäßig
und deshalb habt ihr hoffentlich
verständnis ich rede die ganze nur von
verständnis und was machen will
es war vielleicht nicht so die optimale
entscheidung heute alleine aufzunehmen
nach der deutsch klaus so weil ich da
sowieso schon ein bisschen brain
fakt war sagt man solche bösen wörter
ich glaube nicht
zack zack med deshalb durchaus immer so
einen slot schon relativ stressig
manchmal und ja wir können nichts machen
bum bum ich weiß nicht wie ihr können
wir auch gern mal die kommentare
schreiben beschäftigt sich jemand anders
schon mit black magic oder hat jemand
anders schon gesagt dass er das auch
machen möchte wir haben es auf jeden
fall die hälfte der blöcke es wird aber
nicht mehr ganz funktionieren
wir holen schon mal unseren alltag
gleich hoch so war hier in die mitte
können wir noch mal irgend einem anderen
block drunter machen da oben drauf kommt
der altar hier kommt noch ein hier kommt
ein hier und hier acht komme ich hier
herkomme
ok-chef peter auch jetzt wieder
irgendwie haye oder sowas check gerne
täter in der vg gucken aber das wirklich
macht oder ob ich mir gerade zu unrecht
vorwürfe mache zurzeit es wieder fertig
herr damit und rein damit
aber das wird heute nichts mehr werden
noch zwei minuten
ich habe das gefühl dass doch ein
bisschen zu lange ich dachte mir
wirklich wir machen das ganze sie ganz
flott aber darf ich auf jeden fall
getäuscht ist aber auch halb so wild
finde ich also waren wir das hier noch
irgendwie eine macht hier genau das dach
obendrauf
wobei der muss ja eigentlich noch eine
etage hin
zack zack zack und zeigt läuft hier
wieder die usa und major und sonst was
manche das wetter fertig los mal die uhr
gucken beim nächsten mal das seht ihr
ein bisschen produktivitätssteigerung
betreiben kann
in dem hier war das zeigt die ganze zeit
rein raus rein raus
ihr versteht was ich meine zack zack
zack zack zack
also wie gesagt eine gas trainer ich
hab' kommission im dungeon falls du eine
gasttrainer finde es gibt sie noch mal
schön gebettet war dann kann nicht
fliegen deutlich während liegen das wäre
kugel minecraft galaxy um hier auch so
gefreut sie geflogen bin am anfang okay
ja das ist ein kommers kleine revanche
für die zahllosen rettungen habe aber
noch keine her schön nicht so schlimm
die gibt's auf dem letzten und
vorletzten layer wenn ich wenn mich
nicht alles täuscht so mein blatt magic
alltag kann auch ruhig unter der freien
luft sein finde ich und wir nähern uns
leider dem ende leute einiges geschafft
heute einiges geschafft heute
ich glaube jetzt so allmählich müsste
die folge beenden ich spende noch mal
ein ganzes gut vielleicht nämlich direkt
noch ein aufwand sich irgendwie er was
irgendwie läuft gerade
andererseits kommentiere ich ja und der
folge irgendwie schon die ganze zeit so
schrecklich aber es nervt mit den stars
okay ich gehe mal vom server bei ich
kenne vom server und das war's von heute
bist du nicht mal tschüss